lorsque la grippe aviaire qu'est-ce que
vous avez inventé alors fred vous allez
vous êtes fous de ma gueule
pas du tout je sais ce que vous avez
inventé nous avons un grand manteau en
matière plastique transparent pour pas
trop parce que les corbeaux de la peste
parce qu'en fait ça se transmet un
sessad anaïs emery le problème c'est que
les masques y en aura pas voilà ça on
sait cinca problèmes de production en
quantité la grippe elle arrivera bon à
90 % de risques ça veut dire quoi 90%
tous les champs d'épidémiologie calcule
le risque de mutation à 90% de
probabilités voir sans qu'on semble donc
qu'elle arrive la grippe et non d'ici
cinq ans maintenant se préparer de
fabriquer la cape
car même si on avait des masques il faut
des lunettes parce que ça rentre par les
muqueuses des yeux
et puis c'est un aérosol quand on se
parle là combien ces trois maintenant
que ça on éternuements toux de mettre en
paroles
donc c'est un halo sûr que les
bouteilles d'evian coach donc ça se
déposent l'aérosol dans les cheveux
c'est pourquoi ils nous le disent passe
à la télévision
alors je le dis ça se déposent partout
donc 60% des rues sommes à peu près en
les attrapant avec la caf et on fait ça
on ramasse l'aérosol des gouttelettes de
pluie
je suis en fait c'est s'appelle des
postillons mais qu'on se compliquer et
donc et comme le virus de la grippe vie
3 4 heures à l'air libre
si on fait ça qu'après un chasseur bien
c'est bien et tranquille dans ce café
viendra donc la cape faut pas moi je
détestais à la maison c'est
indispensable ses arrières
le quoi le z derrière un nom il faudra
qu'on puisse être autonome ne pas se
mettre dans les mains du gouvernement
qui ne pourra pas alimenter les gens en
quarantaine du corps pas de masquer ce
qui va le faire nous apporter à manger
donc pour en fait ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est la dislocation sociale l'épidémie
tombe en trois jours on devient des
brutes faut le savoir il faut arriver à
avoir une autonomie pendant une ou deux
heures pour aller faire ses courses un
pas indispensable qu'on se remette pas
comme des bébés en disant que fait
l'état l'état pourra pas faire grand
chose et le tamiflu c'est très compliqué
ça marche dans les 48 heures de la
teinte alors les gars les médecins
comment ils savent en 48 heures où sont
les hypocondriaques les grippes aviaire
et les grippes saisonnières
donc avec une cape en sort ce cap en
plastique transparent mais on polar on
peut l'attaquer on peut faire des trucs
marrants de sécréter peut se mettre tout
nu en dessous blaguer et la cape
m'intéresse c'est de forcer le virus
intrants à à saint pacte et sur le
plastique et descend jusqu'au sol pour
qu'il aille se condenser avec les
gouttelettes
il est toujours au sol explique nous
parce que le virus va frapper un mardi
gras c'est la seule raison qu'on se pose
évidemment ça paraît rigolo nous vous
serez bien content que je vous lis vos
rêves
alors je prévois pour les angoisses et
moi je suis resté une heure de soucis
fermeture éclair oui deux manèges
dommages au son de the artist est
autrement
2 comme ça respire normalement on voit
quelqu'un à 5 mètres pour les
hypocondriaques dit m on referme les
fermetures c'est comme les voitures côte
phares côte pacifique
mais ça va durer un mois de passer un
mois c'est rien glander connaît s'ils
ont mal à capuche n'aura pas parce que
il ya une place dans les hôpitaux avec
des tatouages de cette fameuse cape
mais n'existe pas je suis pas trop
critiquer la maison avec ma soeur
l'intérêt ce que je veux c'est un truc
qu'on puisse fabriquer à la maison parce
que qu'on retombe pas soin des masses et
être tributaire des notions qui ne
pourra pas produire donc ce qui m'amuse
c'est de voir si on peut effectivement
le fabriquer la maison le truc dans le
dos fait c'est un fil de fer très fin
pour que le plastique reste là
combien tout ça c'est pour aller faire
ses courses
ouais c'est pas plus pratique de se
faire livrer je sais pas je pose la
question qui va livrer sans lecteur à la
cape
[Musique]